[Music]
on this friday night the deepening
danger of staying in afghanistan
the threat of more attacks as the window
is closing on getting people out we will
be the victims of uh this warfare and
black
bloodshed
how the us is now forced to align with
the taliban to battle a common enemy the
patchwork of provincial vaccine passport
plans we really want to avoid that the
potential solution to avert
complications and confusion the dilemma
of undecided voters one party doesn't
fit all of them their biggest concerns
and silver's success canada's medal
count grows at the paralympics
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
on the outskirts of kabul's airport
crowds of afghans are not giving up even
after yesterday's horrific attack
hundreds of people tried to find a way
onto a flight desperate to flee the
taliban
good evening thank you for joining us
more evacuation flights are getting out
of kabul but the clock is ticking
because we are now just four days away
from the u.s withdrawal and with
canada's rescue mission now over
thousands of vulnerable people who would
hope to come here
are now stuck
today the federal government urged them
not to give up
hope let me be clear
we will not stop looking for other paths
to bring these people home we will
continue
to have discussions with our partners
and explore avenues for them to return
to canada
we'll have more on canada's response in
a moment but we begin in kabul where
people trapped under taliban rule are
now also grieving after yesterday's
deadly attack there are reports at least
170 people are dead at least 200 others
were wounded redmond shannon has
tonight's top story and a warning some
of the images are distressing
funerals for the victims of thursday's
deadly bombing there are dozens more
including for children killed simply
trying to escape
our hearts are on fire says this man
when would the killings end
the people who died lived in fear of the
taliban but were murdered instead by an
affiliate of the so-called islamic state
isis horusan they're definitely trying
to push an ideology but they're also
promoting an alternative islamist state
so they're compromising the taliban's
monopoly formed by radical pakistani
taliban members seven years ago despite
warnings that another attack could
happen some afghans are still desperate
to get to the airport but taliban
roadblocks are everywhere and the
flights are winding down spain and
australia the latest countries to end
their evacuations britain not far behind
the main processing has now closed
and we have a matter of hours u.s
flights will be the last to leave before
the mission ends on tuesday more afghans
are now fleeing by land across the
border to pakistan
this man says he had been at kabul
airport for days but gave up and headed
to the border instead we are preparing
for around 500 000 new refugees in the
region this is a worst case scenario
it's going to grow you know some of the
other countries in the region uh you
know have indicated that they don't want
to take afghan refugees if commercial
flights from kabul soon return they
could allow those with visas to leave
pending permission from the taliban of
course when it comes to
afghans who don't have that
documentation it's going to be much
harder for them to leave western
governments including canada's say
they're doing all they can to help those
trying to leave but come august 31st the
taliban's control here will be absolute
redmond shannon global news
while the debate over whether the u.s
should withdraw continues what isn't
being debated is how poorly the
withdrawal has been handled the u.s
plans on removing all troops in the next
four days while many afghans fear their
country is on the brink of a new civil
war and as jackson proskow reports they
want help from the u.s canada and other
allies
under threat of imminent attack and a
looming deadline for departure the u.s
led airlift continues we have seen
firsthand how dangerous that mission is
but isis will not deter us from
accomplishing this mission
the death of more than a dozen american
soldiers and dozens of afghans at the
hands of isis k has not changed the
fundamental goal
getting as many people out before august
31st no matter what we will be the
victims of
this warfare and bloodshed
shukla zodran spoke with us from kabul
she's staying for now but fear is being
caught in a new war between isis k and
the ruling taliban i really really hope
that international community
should step in otherwise uh it will not
only uh it will not only challenge the
security of afghanistan but it will
challenge the security of the entire
region and the entire
world we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
in response to thursday's attack
president biden has ordered the pentagon
to develop a list of potential isis-k
targets though the u.s remains squarely
focused on leaving not future
interventions we will be
able to fly out evacuees
right up until the last moment that's
going to be the goal the pentagon will
house up to 50 000 afghan evacuees at
u.s military bases
while scaling back remaining troops over
the next few days
what happens without an american
presence remains a grave question for
the people of afghanistan even after
we're gone at whatever point we need to
use our leverage to try to induce
a more moderate form of taliban rule
going forward indefinitely
for now there's an uneasy alliance
between two former enemies who found
common cause targeting isis k
the u.s has made it clear it does not
trust the taliban amidst this hasty and
devastating exit americans have no
choice but to
jackson prosko global news washington
today prime minister justin trudeau
defended his government's response in
afghanistan the issue continues to dog
the liberal leader on the campaign trail
he says canada is working day and night
to get afghans to safety but he offered
little information as to how abigail
beeman reports
we need to keep each other safe hoping
to focus on vaccines the liberals made
an announcement at a restaurant owned by
syrian refugees but again attention
wrapped on the thousands of afghan
refugees hoping to have a similar
canadian success story we did everything
we could
but of course it got
even more intense more quickly than
everyone expected blaming the rapid and
deadly taliban takeover trudeau stressed
canada is working around the clock to
find ways to get people out committed to
resettling 20 thousand afghans it is the
largest airlift in history a flank of
ministers tried to reassure canadians
bureaucracy is not moving at the snail's
pace being reported by those in
afghanistan so desperate to get to
safety yesterday
our output was increased over two
hundred and fifty percent with average
wait times being only two and a half
minutes the government says it's working
with nearby countries waiving some fees
and has a special envoy to afghanistan
who's on the ground in qatar if you're
not there you can't play former diplomat
colin robertson believes canada needs to
get back into afghanistan to help get
people out move in as quickly as
possible and again i underline that
diplomatic recognition is not a seal of
approval of that government it's simply
how we do business
the government says regional partners
are talking with the taliban trying to
convince them to keep the airport open
the argument is being presented that
it's in the advantage of the country to
have an open airport because it's a
landlocked country but the august 31st
deadline is just days away and the
canadian government won't get into
specifics about what's happening on the
ground even on the question of whether
they'll beef up diplomatic staff in
nearby regions we asked and trudeau
wouldn't answer abigail beeman global
news nobleton ontario
the opposition has also been highly
critical of the federal government's
response in afghanistan and today
conservative leader aaron o'toole
finally laid out his party's plan for
dealing with the crisis
but experts warn there are no easy
answers michael couture is traveling
with a conservative campaign mike
welfare for days aaron o'toole refused
to say exactly what he'd do differently
compared to justin trudeau to help
people trying to flee afghanistan then
thursday evening he released a studio
produced video with a three-part plan
rededicate ourselves to work with our
allies and afghanistan's neighbors in
addition to that o'toole said he would
work with neighboring countries like
india to create safe humanitarian and
refugee corridors also the conservative
leader says he'd provide political and
material support to afghans resisting
the taliban at a press conference friday
he said support would include
intelligence sharing and satellite
imaging but it was unclear if as prime
minister o'toole would help arm those
who oppose the taliban yes or no would
you give them weapons to fight the
taliban that's giving material and
political support that is not meant to
be offensive it's meant to protect it's
meant to provide assistance intelligence
to help isolate and keep the taliban
away from areas where they could harm
people
o'toole added that providing flak
jackets could also help keep people safe
on the ground as for providing safe
routes out of the country defense
analysts say that could be difficult
given the current geopolitical situation
of the region you're going to need to
basically make it safe for these people
to leave very unsafe afghanistan to not
just go into a worse situation or also
unsafe situation somewhere else the
bottom line is like that all is
much more difficult
than trying to bring people from outside
an airport to get inside the airport and
then get on a canadian plane and that
option is totally gone david perry like
most everyone else looking at this
crisis wishes more could have been done
a month ago
pharah
michael couture thank you mike
turning now to the pandemic children age
12 and up will now be able to get the
modern vaccine health canada says it is
safe and effective at preventing covet
19 infection in older kids until today
moderna was only available to adults
this is the second covet 19 vaccine to
be authorized for kids over the age of
12. pfizer received the stamp of
approval in may and there is still no
approved covid19 vaccine for younger
children but clinical trials are
underway
manitoba is bringing back its mask
mandate starting tomorrow face coverings
will once again be required in all
indoor public spaces the province is
also bringing in new immunization
measures starting in september anyone
wanting to go to a sporting event a
restaurant or a gym will need to be
fully vaccinated and as jamie morocco
explains the liberals hope new funding
will push other provinces to follow suit
with vaccine passports
a vaccine mandate for non-essential
businesses
is a good idea and one the liberal
leader says his government is willing to
fund offering to cover the cost for any
province implementing a vaccine passport
so far that just includes british
columbia quebec and manitoba these
mandates to say that you have to prove
vaccination status in order to do the
activities which we're used to
can be a very helpful nudge in bc alone
the day after its announcement covet 19
vaccination bookings rose 124 percent
reaching all eligible canadians remains
a challenge now you're asking for public
health information
and
to me you know that opens a can of worms
that i'm not willing in any way
to entertain i can't believe that there
wasn't sort of a universal
thing all over canada to do it in
alberta jason kenney has repeatedly
refused the idea of a vaccine passport
meantime sources in ontario tell global
news doug ford's government is
considering a proof of vaccination
proposal after months of stopping short
we really want to avoid that patchwork
it can be it could be an undue cause and
undue burden on small businesses and on
individuals
after already a very trying 17 months
ottawa has only committed to a vaccine
passport for international travel the
federal government doesn't have
the vaccination status of all canadians
that's a provincial health care
responsibility a decision that if left
up to each individual premier could
create more confusion than cohesion
jamie morocco global news toronto
well liberal leader justin trudeau
pushed provinces to mandate vaccines
during his campaign stop this morning he
dodged questions about his own event
that appeared to break covet 19 capacity
rules in ontario
there are definitely more than 25 people
in this fairly tight and crowded space
are you breaking the spirit if not the
letter of the lock i think canadians are
facing a really important choice right
now but we're going to continue
to remind canadians that the big
decisions about our future they're being
made now i'm not sure that was an answer
to my question so did you get special
clearance to hold an event that exceeds
current crowd capacity in ontario
indoors
we're going to continue to do everything
we can
to keep people safe
we
expect all of our candidates to be
vaccinated
trudeau like other leaders are
crisscrossing the country vying for your
vote coming up what the polls are
suggesting about who could win on
election night
the federal election campaign has been
underway for less than two weeks but
polls show the race is tightening the
liberal's quest for a majority
government may turn into a battle to
hold on to power
new polling done exclusively for global
news looks at public reception of
canada's potential prime ministers eric
sorenson reports
justin trudeau's campaign kicked off
riding a wave of approval that it held
steady throughout the pandemic but
questions around an early election call
and the crisis in afghanistan have
forced the liberal leaders focus from
campaign promises to crisis management
this is a very difficult day
not just for afghans
but for people around the world
including in canada the opposition able
to keep alive the question why an
election now mr trudeau has provided no
reason for the election and no plan i
don't think canadians can afford another
four years of justin trudeau ipsos found
trudeau's favorable ratings are now
exceeded by unfavorable his net rating
stands at -12. conservative leader aaron
o'toole's net favorability is lower at
-21 but ndp leader jagmeet singh at plus
six is the only leader with a net
positive rating jackman sings absolutely
become an asset for the ndp ticket
and he is clearly somebody particularly
i would say progressive voters are
prepared to take a look at and while
aaron o'toole's ratings remain low he's
also the least well known and polls show
the conservatives gaining ground
canadians deserve sensing liberal
vulnerability o'toole and singh are both
targeting the greater toronto area where
elections can be decided
it was in the gta in the 2015 election
that the liberals built an electoral
bastion even reduced to a minority in
2019 the red fortress held but when
things start to turn it can look like
2008. the stephen harper conservatives
won seats in the so-called 905 belt and
the ndp downtown by 2011 the liberals
nightmare the conservatives and ndp
attacked from the right and the left and
took over much of toronto from north to
south and we are going to keep fighting
the favorable response to seeing is
partly his appeal to young voters on
platforms like tick-tock
but o'toole is better positioned the
conservatives already within striking
distance of the liberals
a five-week campaign leaves the
challengers little time to overtake an
incumbent prime minister but if the race
really begins to swing the other way
justin trudeau will also have less time
to right the ship erik sorensen global
news toronto
from the olympics to the paralympics
ahead the inspiring canadian comeback in
tokyo
and with that another medal added to
canada's hall in tokyo at the
paralympics canada's flag bear priscilla
gagne grappling her way to second place
in the women's 52 kilogram category in
judo it's her first paralympic medal
and track cyclist kate o'brien made an
impressive and inspiring debut at the
paralympics she didn't end up getting
the gold the 33 year old calgarian
finished second in women's c4 500 meter
time trial it caps off a remarkable
comeback story o'brien competed for team
canada in rio in 2016. a bike crash in
2017 left her in a coma with a major
brain injury doctors initially weren't
sure she'd survive or even walk again
through intense rehabilitation she's
been able to return to competitive
cycling
up next i speak with some of canada's
undecided voters what will it take for a
federal party to win them over
ahead of september 20th election day
global nationals traveling across the
country to talk to you the viewers the
voters we want to know what matters to
canadians from coast to coast to coast
while in vancouver recently i spoke to
people who consider themselves undecided
voters i asked them about what matters
most this election and what might push
them to make a decision
tell me a bit about yourself i'm 69 i'm
a senior i'm retired from the vancouver
school board as an educator and i would
love to see more affordable housing for
my children and grandchildren would you
say affordability and housing is your
number one issue this election housing
and ethics and government is my are my
two main issues ethics in government
tell me a bit more about that well i
think our current federal government has
been not transparent with us and so i'm
really undecided as to who to vote for
to actually get rid of this government
is there anything that the liberals
could do to get back your trust and your
vote the way they've treated jodie
wilson raybould the way they've treated
indigenous people it's just been really
awful to watch the only way to win back
my trust for the liberals is to get rid
of trust fund justin trudeau so for you
it's really about him it's about voting
him out i'm leading either ndp or
conservative which everyone has the best
chance of getting rid of justin trudeau
my name is jimmy
i'm 28 years old i'm a fashion designer
and a graphic designer and that's why
you're dressed so well so jimmy tell me
about your number one issue this
election definitely climate change i
feel like that's the larger issue
because a lot of the wildfires or even
like drought like lack of food all that
comes back to like how we treat the
earth and manage our resources and so
what do you need to hear from political
leaders right now on that file on
climate to get your vote just keep what
you're saying because that's what i'm
rolling on and that's what i trusted you
when i put the ballot in are you leaning
one way or the other or are you gonna
vote strategically one party doesn't fit
all of them you know they all have
different things that they value and all
that so i guess it's kind of seeing
where my ballot would have the best bang
for the buck i'm marsh i'm from winnipeg
uh just turned 18 graduated this june so
for me the election the two main
contenders would be the climate right
and how we affect that as a nation and
also our international effect on like
the rest of the world right and how we
deal with these crises that are popping
up all of a sudden all over the world so
you're you're 18 in your first election
would it be fair to say that you're
still undecided yeah right now
definitely you need to trust whoever's
going to be leading you and controlling
your fate and also that they're willing
to invest in my future because i'm so
young and you know very little time to
decide so i have to start reading up my
social studies again
better brush up just over three weeks to
go and that is global national for this
friday night i'm farah nasser thank you
so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your canada is
the perseid meteor shower over moraine
lake near lake louise alberta earlier
this month robin gill will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow until next week
take care of yourselves and each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you